donald trump has absolutely lost it
on his new blog over the news
that a grand jury has been convened in
manhattan to evaluate evidence that
donald trump
and or his associates and or his
organization have committed crimes
as a reminder we already outlined that
the washington post reports a
grand jury panel has been convened and
it will sit three days a week for six
months they will be looking at all sorts
of different
possible crimes that trump associates
and his organization
may have committed donald trump reacting
immediately triggered which is exactly
what we've predicted for a long time
which is if these criminal probes get
going once trump is out of office
trump is going to lose his mind and he's
already losing his mind and nothing has
even happened yet
let's review his blog post where donald
trump opens by saying
this is a continuation of the greatest
witch hunt in american history
it began the day i came down the
escalator in trump tower and it's never
stopped
they wasted two years and 48 million in
taxpayer dollars on mueller and russia
russia russia now remember the mueller
probe
recovered more money than it cost trump
goes on to say impeachment hoax number
one
impeachment hoax number two and it
continues to this day with
illegally leaked confidential
information
no other president in history has had to
put up with what i have had to
and on top of all that i have done a
great job for our country
whether it's taxes regulations are
military veterans space force our border
speedy creation of a great vaccine said
to be a miracle
and protecting the second amendment we
could do an hour debunking each of those
this is purely political and an affront
to the almost 75 million voters who
supported me
in the presidential election and it's
being driven by a har
by highly partisan democrat prosecutors
new york city and state are suffering
the highest crime rates in history
that's not true
and instead of going after murderers
drug dealers human traffickers and
others they come after donald trump
interesting that today a poll came out
indicating i'm
far in the lead for the republican
presidential primary
and the general election in 2024 that's
not true not that second part
and lastly trump says our country is
broken
our elections are rigged corrupt and
stolen
not true our prosecutors are politicized
and i will just have to keep on fighting
like i have been for the last
five years trump off the rails and
just imagine if there are charges just
imagine if there are charges what will
happen with this man's
psyche donald trump jr getting in on the
action retweeting someone named mike
davis
who said quote since 1923 the trump
family has built a worldwide real estate
and hospitality empire
now highly partisan democrat prosecutors
are
on a witch hunt to find paperwork
crimes crimes and quotes and they ignore
clear evidence of foreign corruption and
other real crimes
by the biden crime family folks it is
conspiracies all the way down
you know the phrase it's turtles all the
way down it is conspiracies
just all the way down and this is going
to be a very interesting six months
the timeline that is mentioned would be
in if there will be indictments around
the end of summer
and then starting to get into court
and seeing what direction these
indictments will go in the fall
so between now and november potentially
just a a a series of
never-ending um insanity
is what we are expecting to see here
we have on monday memorial day an
incredible
one day david pakman show membership
special
we have had a lot of membership
attrition due to the continued
financial strain that many people are
under that's sad and i understand that
hundreds of members cancelling over the
last couple of months
we are trying to do something to turn
that around
and that is that monday memorial day
we're doing a single day membership
special i would love for you to
participate
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com and then monday morning
you'll hear all about it all right
quick break let me know on twitter what
do you expect to come of this grand jury
you can find me on twitter at d pacman
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills
each one down into an e-book or
audiobook
that you can get through in just 15
minutes where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video